all right so before we move on before we
move on from the hot foods
um so how long do you guys feel like you
can
survive on convenience store food before
you start to get bored of it well i
actually tried that out once
uh when i why because it was the only
option i had so
basically when i was actually it was the
only option you had well let me let me
explain when i was working i was like 16
i was working at the ski fields in
hokkaido right right i'm in the middle
of [ __ ] nowhere in hong kong oh
in the mountains the only thing they had
i'm 16 as well so i can't drive to the
next you can't afford a fancy meal ever
i can't afford fans basically i'm living
day by day with what they're paying me
right yeah yeah
and also because it's snowing [ __ ] 24
7 there right
without a car you're basically [ __ ]
like you can't walk in
you know into a snow storm to like go to
the next town
financial advisor not even my financial
advisor could save me
but so the only thing they had around
where i was staying
was a family mart oh that's why you're a
family master
so i literally throughout that entire
month
i i would want to say minimum two meals
a day
every day for a month was family mart
yeah and you know what
i felt like i wanted to die by the end
of it
there's only so much like first week
you're just like all right i'm going to
try that bento i'm going to try that
bento
basically i like i like fully completed
the pokedex of like family mart food
yeah i was like yeah i tried everything
and once i did finish
everything i was like i highly regret
that i did that
because i feel so [ __ ] unhealthy
right now because the thing is
when you come when you come to japan for
the first time and you see
how just how much choice of meals there
are
in every convenience stores especially
for me coming from england
where the only choice i have is the
tesco's meal deal
come on don't don't talk ill of like the
best thing that we have about our
country
but there's in terms of like let's say
packageable
lunches or meals that you can get away
with
not even though that's what i think
pastries
that's kind of about it really we do
have something you've got sandwiches you
got
i think we all have the problem with the
uk stuff that you can like kind of take
quickly it's all
in like the same genre and the food the
thing like it does there's no there's no
variety yeah yeah and the thing is only
say
only like the big super mega stores have
the hot food like the fresh
chicken food is good like sometimes you
you go to like sainsbury's it's the big
sainsbury's and they have like the hot
rotisserie chickens
those actually slap but tesco's have
like the sausage like yeah like
footlong sausage that you can eat
[ __ ] amazing but those but those are
limited to like the really really big
stores um
so the good thing about convenience
stores is that all this
like everything you see is basically
homogenous throughout basically every
convenience store you can find
there are some that are bigger that have
even more choice
of what you can buy but we are
showcasing stuff that you can buy
basically every convenience store you
can get in i do think when you
actually living here it's sort of like
you view convenience food almost like
mcdonald's in my mind like
yeah it starts to have like a almost
it's not mcdonald's characteristic to
the
taste of how you know it's not like it's
not all fresh it doesn't all
taste quite like something's been a
little too
not as healthy as they package it yeah
right i mean there are definitely some
healthy things like there's some decent
salads there's some stuff like that and
like
i mean after the gym i think we always
uh we always just get like there's just
chicken breasts
yeah so so they have literally you have
one of them right um
do i have a chicken breast you might
have one did you did you buy a chicken
breasts
that's just a sausage just it's it's
called it's from johnsonville an amazing
name
it's an american brand i think so you
can just rip it open and you start
eating it
one sausage what what what i do have
it's not a chicken
breast something similar like that but
they literally have uh this is
this this is a a salad chicken bar i
don't know what a salad chicken bar is
what the [ __ ]
um it's like a salad in a bar with
chicken what the [ __ ]
is that no chicken has ever been in that
shape what is that
it's like a chicken sausage almost so
normally the ones that i get and they
also have a family mart and lawson so i
don't know why they
wouldn't uh have them at some point it's
like a salad chicken
nuggets imagine literally a chicken
breast seasoned i think the one that i
always go for is tandoori flavor
chicken tandoori it's literally just a
chicken breast just in a
uh vacuum sealed package that is just a
vacuum sealed
vacuum seal package like this yeah you
crack that bad boy open at like 3am
you go for a yeah right you know you
want to get some protein what's the best
source of protein just eat a [ __ ]
whole chicken breast yeah
20 grams of protein boom you're talking
because normally like if
it's it's it makes it so convenient
because no matter what mood or no matter
what kind of food you want
they probably have it at your
convenience store if you want something
healthy
you can oh god that looks awful this
this this this this
that looks like oh show the gloss to the
camera
oh my god look at that yo give me a bite
of that give me
let's cut that this is glossier than
some nails jesus christ
that looks vile yeah let me try that let
me try that where's the knife actually
get us together
okay go ahead one of those oh yeah yeah
oh this feels you know what this it
feels plastic i'll try it but i'm not
going to cut it i'm not going to like it
this looks like a
like a hot dog with extra peppers on it
honestly oh my god it tastes like a
chicken hot dog
that's [ __ ] weird okay that's just a
i don't know if you were supposed to
take the skin off of those though no
no no no it's a chicken hot dog i like
how they call it
a salad chicken when it's just a chicken
hot chocolate
well then japan's not not gonna know
what chicken hotdog is probably it's
[ __ ] awful
you know do you know what they call corn
dogs here yeah american dog america dogs
i mean honestly that's a pretty [ __ ]
good name yeah it's pretty accurate name
it's like what are the hot dogs that
they eat in america corn dogs